hey guys what's up this is andrew for
consensus.com
so this is day number four for me in my
quarantine hotel
and i'm full of energy so i want to use
all this energy guys to make
an update on amc and discuss everything
that we have said yesterday in my
discord let's get into it
[Music]
and guys so a lot of things have been
said a lot of things
happened let's go through everything
let's analyze this price action on the
short term let's try to find the
different scenarios
let's see what are the probabilities
that according to me
are to be given to each of these
scenarios and let's find out
what's interesting option strategy we
could make at this levels
let me remind you a bit the situation so
we are having this correction
that i'm now labeling abc it was a wxy
i'm back now to abc because c waves
contain five waves
here definitely this wave has five waves
so let me
level it so one
two and the question is three
four five four three
four and five all right so this is the
question i'm having guys i posted this
yesterday once again in my discord and i
told you guys that
we have two scenarios either we go to 43
then we get slightly rejected we break
it and we do the one two three four five
or we go to 42 43 and get rejected right
away
and go to 24 before bouncing back
then this would be like this and i had
another scenario
that is like very unlikely that he's
even going lower but
i mean you know there is almost zero
chance that 24
is not acting as support if we go there
so
right now here what happened guys so let
me first
get rid of this one and zoom in here a
little bit
so i was with you guys all the way here
all the way up
we had the breakout i was telling you
here guys that it was not the right time
to buy
that this breakout would be retested
like it is 90
of the time it was retested here at the
end of
thursday's session then on friday i told
you that we are heading to 42 43
but that after this kind of strong moves
down
there is usually some re-tests of the
lows
and usually you have some noise and
the market is volatile i was basically
saying that we are very
likely to re-test this 33-34 level
and this is exactly what happened at the
end of the day so right now the question
is are we still going to 42 43
or is it possible that we break to the
33
31 level and all this area and go to 24
right away so i'm gonna try to answer
this question
to do that and once again i'm sorry guys
when i do my scenarios
you know i try to give you the big
pictures but in each scenario of course
there are many scenarios and
here one of the scenario is that you
know i checked the fibs
i measured this last wave that we have
just broken and
i want to know if the retracement that i
have here
is big enough to be complete so i check
this and i see that here we don't
even reach the 50 retracement level we
go roughly to the 38.2 it's here okay
38.2 percent retracement level which is
kind of unlikely
so to meet this correction of this move
even if we go lower
it doesn't look like it's complete okay
first thing
now if this entire move is to be
finished
you know guys that here we need to have
an impulse
this first wave needs to be in five ways
but right now this is not what we're
having guys okay
here i struggle a bit to try to find
five waves you know because sometimes
you can but here it's impossible guys
you don't have five waves
i mean you know something is missing so
this is an abc game
no question about that this is an abc
so this looks for me corrective guys all
right this looks corrective
and if this is correct if the question
is are we going to have an abc like this
or is it already complete both cases
are possible here what would then happen
if so
my first scenario let me do again the
one two three four five that are
here so one and you can see that here i
have an abc that is a flat so you guys
know
about elliott wave theory now because
i'm telling a lot about it here
that when the second wave is a flat
usually
the force corrective wave is a zigzag
so for those who are interested to know
more about eliot wave theory
just click on the link in the
description of this video and you're
gonna access a free
training that i did a few months ago
where i explained everything
about elliot i mean you know everything
that you need to start
learning and practicing and your theory
and i'm talking about this relation that
we have
between the second and the fourth wave
so here this is a hint
you have a flat here so you can expect a
zigzag so once again
i'm not sure guys if the zigzag is here
the small abc i have
or is it going to be a bigger abc but in
both cases as long as i don't have five
waves here
i can't say that this correction is
complete and i'm still a bit afraid that
we revisit the 24 area the main reason
behind that is that here i have an abc i
don't have a one two three four five
now let me try to find a more bullish
scenario
so this is my first scenario guys my
second scenario
is that this is complete
and then here somehow we're gonna have a
one two three four five so this must be
a one
two all right and we can have three four
five it's still possible all right
it's still possible but then the first
wave would still be an abc
guys all right even if i zoom i'm here
in a 15 minutes time frame guys
okay 15 minute time frame so then you
can maybe do one
two three four five all right there is
always a way to find a small
first wave but it's not very clean let's
be honest alright so for now
my intuition is telling me that this is
an abc so
this is an abc2 and it doesn't look very
good to me i need more bullish signals
to really feel confident that this first
wave is developing for now
i'm not having it but it might arrive
maybe later
so right now 34 for me is the support
the first support level so if we break
34 guys
of course it doesn't look good it gives
even more weight the first scenario that
we go to
24 but be careful once again it's not
because
we go to 42 now because this is a
downward sloping trend line so the level
will be
42 42.5 that things look good all right
this could still be a corrective wave
that would then be followed by
a fist wave so what you guys really want
to see
once again is this kind of behavior
all right and this is what we had
exactly here guys and once again i gave
you this trade in my discord channel i
told you
what level to buy and of course for now
you know if you buy here and you have a
selling order at 43
you wouldn't have made any profit i know
that you guys don't want to day trade
amc i'm just
saying that for now the trade i gave you
was not a winner but
if you enter the street at this 34 level
either
you average down and buy lower 24 or you
just stop loss right below
i mean this is a day trading technique
and once again it's not for everyone
to be a dad trader guys you need to have
a lot of time you need to be
very focused on the market to have very
strong nerves and it's a bit risky so
it's not what most investors should do
but
this is just some techniques for those
who are interested all right so i think
i discussed
here the cases so right now we are still
looking for some hints about
if yes or not this is a reversal that
we're having so of course this would be
the perfect hint just like we have here
the typical breakout guys
alright so let me get rid of it for now
we can look for some
candle formation reversals like you know
bullish and girl thing
stuff like this here we almost have a
bullish engulfing on the forest time
frame
but it's not very clear i'm sorry
and on the daily time frame we don't
have anything right
we don't have any candle formation that
looks like
a reversal so for now the only reversal
we are having
is here on the you better sit on the 20
minutes time
frame is that we broke
finally this maybe fifth wave that is
complete or not i don't know
but we have here the breakout this is
the only bullish reversal we have
of course the media is moving higher i
want to show you something very cool i
want to talk about option strategy and
as you can see guys i set up my account
so i am right now on interactive brokers
so it has always been my account but i
put some money now
i don't put a lot i just put like around
four thousand us dollars i'm not gonna
take trades right away once again i need
to confirm if everything is fine you
know me
taking trade in front of you on youtube
being still
employee by my company in september i'm
not sure exactly about
how things would go i can show you some
cool options strategies but just before
that
i need to remind you guys something very
very important that i was discussing as
well yesterday in my discord
you know you have this high dollar
crypto money that has just
been created by a group of my friends in
hong kong very rich people
and i just had the one of the founders
yesterday over the phone for 45 minutes
he explained to me everything so i'm
gonna make
a full video just on it but i'm taking
some time here to tell you guys that
it's very important that you subscribe
you sign up guys
uh to this cryptocurrency because you're
gonna receive
free token every day you just give my
name as a referral
because this is a referral system and uh
let me show you something guys
this is growing very fast so right now
you just tap high.com and you can see
the value guys it's been like two months
even less that they created their crypto
and it went from three from like one to
23 so times 23 and right now they have
more than 500 000
users so the price must be even more
expensive so for now
they fix the price themselves but on the
1st of august it's going to be
listed on uni swap guys you're going to
be able to see the real price and i'm
very sure that this thing is gonna go to
the sky
maybe you know not times hundred but
maybe five times five ten
and as soon as you sign up you can claim
your daily rewards and get
free token guys so it's just free money
that you can get it's a free option
so i encourage all of you guys to go
there to sign up and to claim your daily
rewards
and one more thing i have a bet with my
friend he sent me this yesterday so as i
said it's a referral system guys
and i'm not sure exactly if this is
weekly or monthly but
thanks to you guys i am already on the
podium you have more than 500
000 users and i am the number three
in the referrals so it means that a lot
of you have already signed up
and thank you for that but i made a bet
with my friend i told him that after the
weekend i would be number one
so please help me guys to be on the
first step of this podium
thank you so much guys let's see if it
works
so let's go back to what is more
interesting guys let's go back to amc
and i want to show you some cool option
strategies because like i said
i'm going to be trading amc and gme and
everything else soon guys in front of
you what i want to do is actually start
from small money
let's say five ten thousand us dollars
and try to show you
how we go higher you know so i'm just
gonna make small beds small beds
i'm gonna use different strategies
option strategies buying shares
using futures just what i was doing at
work and i'm gonna
show you guys how to grow your account
what i would do in this situation as an
option strategies uh maybe quickly we
can go through the
option of an interest you remember i was
keeping this data
i was having a look at this data very
often before
but i kind of you know lost my
accessories because actually i was
using bloomberg which i was not really
allowed to do but now i can tell you
guys but i don't have access to
bloomberg anymore
so right now it's a bit dependent yes
for me to get all this data here but i
managed to get it i just used some copy
paste from yahoo finance because all the
data is here
i use some vlookup functions guys all
right as you can see here
and i compute the delta myself using
black shoes formula
and i aggregate all this data here so
what is this open interest distribution
telling us you can see that
or most of the collapsions are
concentrated around the 20 and the 40
strike
which are not far out of the money
strikes
i mean the 40 the 20 is in the money but
the 40 is not that out of the money
so it's diffusing already quite a lot so
basically this is not what is going to
create the squeeze we need the 60 70
80 100 you know 145 is quite
uh big that's good but it's very far
away guys it's very far away so before
starting really diffusing
and making creating the gamma squeeze
that market maker would
trigger if amc goes higher we need to
have all the way up
those some gamma positions here some
short gamma positions for market makers
so which means some long cold positions
for retail
here i don't see it and you know
remember you know when amc was at 60
here we were having 12 15 guys of
synthetic short even 20
sometimes so it really ran down guys so
this is the reason why
we have all this loss of momentum as
well and we can see that here we still
have some gamma so around the 40 strand
guys if amc goes higher
there might be some strong moves up you
know but it will not be very extended
for now i think it's going to stay
located around the 50 60 area because
you know when amc will go higher the
market makers shot gamma so if amc goes
higher they need to
buy shares you know the mechanism so
let's have a quick look at the
volatility guys it dropped it dropped
you it was like
around so i take the 145 strikes and now
let's take the
70 strike so it was around 350
for the first here it was 250 so
basically volatility lost 20 25
which is completely normal because amc
is moving uh less
and there is less chance that amc
squeezes when it's at this level at
least this is what market makers are
pricing so right now we can see that if
i take the regular short interest of the
30th of june
data 75 million shares which is around
15 percent of
short interest compared to the flood
chart i add to this the synthetic show
guys that i complete myself
like i just showed you and i come up
with 21
of total shot interest which is half of
what we had
when amc kind of squeezed even if the
squeeze was small yes it was a small
gamma squeeze created by
the option market mostly so we are a bit
far from it we need to rebuild
all these positions before uh really
scaring
market makers and hedge funds so it's a
process that
will take some time just as the reverse
so that i was discussing with you guys
in technical analysis it will take some
time you know there is a lot of
damage that has been done and it needs
time to repair
so this is kind of expected for me and
yeah guys so
right now i want to show you some cool
option strategy so
once again very important guys we just
did some technical analysis now i'm
going to show you some option strategy i
remind you for those maybe who are
watching my video for the first time
that i'm a next option trader i was
working as a option trader for six years
in banking i resigned two of uh two
months ago even yeah one month ago guys
to be here full time with you because i
think it's much more interesting to
share this knowledge with you
and to be in the game myself than
working for a bank
and so here i can tell you what i would
do in this situation so
i remind you technical analysis was
telling us that here
24 so this is kind of the worst case
scenario that can happen you know we
have we don't know if we're gonna break
32 30 you know all this area and go to
24
or if we're gonna right away go to 43
break it re-test and go higher or if
maybe it's gonna be like this as well
you know so that three scenarios either
we break it now we go lower
we go higher or the worst worst case
scenario is this one but guys
you know it's like almost zero percent
chance given the bullishness that we're
having on amc and the 24
price that would be an amazing level for
long term uh buy and hold strategy
so this is the worst worst case scenario
but even in this scenario guys okay
let's take this scenario into account
even in this scenario 24 is
holding guys for one month so i'm very
fine
to sell those foods because if you sell
a food you're losing money only below
24. i don't care
because i know we won't be trading there
we won't be closing there
so i take the 20th of august maturity i
copy-pasted it from yahoo finance guys
this is just the data
and here i do the average because the
the price sometimes is the last trading
price it's not good
so i take the average between the bid
and the ask which is always
a good price i don't take the fees here
into account
so let's say i sell 10 of them so i make
3 000 us dollars
so what then i'm gonna buy with that
guys once again you sell the 24 because
there is a strong support level
so which call are you gonna buy tell me
you're gonna buy
the next support level that is above you
which is fully three guys
all right so you go for 42 even 42
so how much does it cost it costs twice
as much so you only buy five so here you
sell 10 of course
bam and this is a kind of what we call
this
a caller a zero caller strategy so it's
when you
buy some calls and sell some foods to
get a
zero premium strategy and here guys i
will lose
nothing unless amc closes below 24 in
august
which is almost impossible guys so the
probability i lose money here
is close to zero and if amc squeezes
before august i can make for example if
it goes to
100 you know 20 30 40 000
us dollars all right guys so now the
question i'm having
is is this strategy easily credible so
i'm gonna go
on here guys my workstation you're gonna
see this more and more i told you
i'm starting to set up okay so this is
amc so i can't show you everything i
don't know why i cannot
switch it uh anyway but here august
strategy so here i buy a 43
i sell a 24 so i sell a put
i buy a call here is the maturity here
is the strike
i buy a call i sell a put and here you
can see the
margin impact so for now i have a
one-to-one relation
so i want to take i want to sell two
puts
and buy one call and i need 36 000
hong kong dollars all right so i'm not
gonna be able to make this strategy
because i don't put enough money on my
account
but this is the strategy i showed you
and once again there is a 100 multiplier
guys this is the
real option market all right this is i'm
not going through any broker i'm i'm
trading directly on the exchange to
minimize the fees
and here you can see you must enter
valid price so this is costing close to
zero minus zero
four and then zero so let's say i wanna
buy this at minus one for example
um and i'm gonna get rejected because i
have only twenty eight
thousand hong kong dollars and i need
thirty six all right which is around
four thousand us dollars so if i can't
go for this one
i would just increase slightly the
strike here
so i'm sacrificing some upside
performance
i'm gonna here take a bigger strike so
i'm taking some risk between 27 and 24
and i go for one to one
one by one and this is costing zero and
now i have enough money so now i can
buy so it costs zero roughly so i can
buy it at
zero right so i'm going to put minus one
i don't want to be executed because for
now i'm not allowed
and now it is working all right so i'm
not going to transmit it
but this is the kind of strategy that i
would do
guys at work and that i would do in
front of you very soon
all right so i'm not doing this one let
me show you another one
here you go this is my workstation guys
so this is
my trader workstation where i'm gonna
spend a lot of time with you very soon
now another one guys that i told you
about already some time ago guys
that is still good to use the condor
guys you know it's a
it's a good time guys to buy a condor so
you remember which one
this one guys bam bam bam bam so you buy
10 you sell 10. now you buy your cool
spread and you sell a pulse frame
all right here we go so this is the
strategy and you can see that it cost
only 100 dollars so here you might
want to add the fees so let's add the
fees so i consider that
if i'm buying it so this is
now i add zero zero run and if i'm
selling
minus zero zero one so this is the bid
ask spread
okay so it's slightly more expensive so
it's gonna cost you 150 us dollars
and you can make up to ten thousand guys
up up to ten thousand and i took
the bid ask spread into account here so
don't
hesitate to spend some money guys on
those kind of strategies
and you you put some on august some on
september he only have august but it's
going to work as well
very well at september if you believe
that we're going to close one day
between 100 and 135 which i believe
those are my targets so this is how you
associate option trading with technical
analysis guys
and let me try to put this one here so i
go on the option chain
let's see if there is enough so bam
vertical
enough margin to do this so i go on the
20th of august i
select whatever called spread so by
nuclear spread is not problem so let's
see if i can sell the cold spread
so i sell the 135 and i buy this one
so what's the margin but you see guys
the the margin is tiny so i can do
just 10 times with 4 000 us dollars
i need twenty two thousand margin enter
a valid price of course
so this costs a third so i'm buying this
or minus one for example i'm not going
to be executed and this is working all
right
so i have 27 it's only to consume 22
and buying your code spread is almost
for free let's just check
so i sell the 100 and i buy the 90
okay a thousand you see so basically
with 23 000
i have 27 i can put this kind of
strategy
10 by 10 by 10 by 10 and get 10 000
hong kong dollars if amc closes between
100
and 135 on the 20th of august
which is for me you know very possible
so let's see i'm gonna let you know guys
when i'm gonna be really allowed to do
the stress i hope very soon and let's
make some money together
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore i see you guys